fire and blood make poor tools as Kings
make poor servants House Targaryen
called themselves dragons long after the
last beast died perhaps it's only
fitting that even their humility was
monstrous men worshipped on with seniors
Hill thousands of years before Visenya
cave and Baylor raised the sanctum that
bears his name
the massive dome and towers of the great
Sept of Baelor can be seen from anywhere
in the city but not from the vast
countryside that paid for it its Seven
Bells can be heard as far as Dragonstone
whenever a king dies but none tolled for
the stonemasons glaciers and Smith's who
built it the great Sept was built to
impress upon a man how much greater the
gods are than him a noble goal and in
that it succeeds within the main chamber
the Sun streams through a seven-pointed
star to illuminate the seven towering
over mortals the Crone with a lantern
for lost souls the mother with her
welcoming arms the father with his
scales of justice the maiden with her
purity the warrior with his sword
the Smith with his hammer
and lastly the stranger with his shroud
face pilgrims cross the Seven Kingdoms
to light candles here at the feet of
their gods but these aren't the gods the
seven aren't encased in stone in the
great Sept any more than the souls of
dead kings are in the tombs below it to
steward his monument of vanity Bale has
summoned the High Septon of the faith
from his ancient seat in Old Town and
gifted him with ornate robes and a crown
of crystal and gold like a fool the High
Septon put on his lords motley and
danced at his Lords table and with each
passing year the high septons fell ever
lower how can the flock be kept safe
from wolves when the Shepherd sleeps in
their den bailer himself appointed a
simple-minded stonemason believing him
the Smith reborn and when he died
Baelor replaced him with an
eight-year-old boy whom Baylor had seen
speaking with doves that answered with
the voices of the seven still a common
people revere bay long as the blessed
they tell of how he forced a high lord
to wash a beggar's feet first into tame
his unnatural lusts and walked the bone
way himself to make peace with door
many septons and setters even claimed
that bail or rescued his cousin the
dragonknight from a snake pit because no
Viper would strike a man so pure and
holy ally Baylor was bitten a dozen
times and was bedridden for half a year
and yet he didn't die nor that his high
septons ruined the faith blessed Bayless
statue may greet men outside the doors
but when men enter the great Sept they
don't see the gold or the crystal or the
ambitions of a humble member of a
powerful dynasty they see the gods they
feel or at the divine majesty and their
own insignificance the gods work through
Baylor's pride and vanity as they work
through all of us for the faith is more
than a sect the faith is more than a
High Septon more than all the septons
and scepters who preach to the living
more than the silent sisters who prepare
the dead the faith is the will of the
gods
and we are all its instruments kings and
beggars lords and cobblers lions
and sparrows